yeah yeah nice hey guys welcome this is
the real estate investing mastery
podcast and hopefully this is working
we're broadcasting live right now to the
youtubes and Facebook and I'm excited
because we have a special guest his name
is Samuel Leeds and a lot of you in the
US might not have heard of him but
almost everybody from the UK and around
Europe has heard of him this guy is a
property investing beast or as we'll say
here in the US he's a real estate
investing Beast this guy I was I didn't
really know much about Samuel he
contacted me because he's did something
crazy when he came to the US and flipped
a deal while he was here we're going to
talk about that but I started looking at
his YouTube channel his Facebook his
Instagram is like holy smokes this guy
is awesome I like Samuel and he's one of
the most prolific and like in terms of
deals and one of the most sought-after
educators and trainers in England and
I'm honored to have him on the show
today let me first tell you guys if you
want more information about this podcast
we're gonna have sandals going to be
giving you some links and some websites
and places you can go we're gonna keep
all of that in the show notes real
estate investing mastery calm real
estate investing mastery calm and if
you're listening to this on the podcast
just when you when you when you pull
over go to real estate investing mastery
calm and then in the search bar do a
search for Samuel and you'll find this
episode you'll see the transcripts the
links the references and all of the show
notes let me say one more thing in terms
of an announcement please leave your
reviews in iTunes if you like the show
we're on stitcher we're on Spotify we're
on Google Play a bunch of others if you
like the show give us a thumbs up and
say that you liked it leave us a review
would really appreciate it one more
thing - we are live here on YouTube and
Facebook so if you're watching us right
now if you type in the comments let us
know where you are from say hello tell
us where you're from and I bet you
Samuel there's somebody watching right
now from England and so
if you type in the comments and ask your
questions either in YouTube or Facebook
wherever you are even periscope right
now by the way I will ask I'll have a
chance to show the your comment on the
screen here and we'll ask Samuel any
questions you guys have okay
so cool Samuel welcome to the podcast
man how are you dude I'm absolutely
stoked to be on your show so thank you
so much for having me is really good to
connect guys
Samuels got a real cool story I'm gonna
ask him to share in a minute but last
time I was in England Samuel my we
brought our four kids we have four kids
we were we flew into London it was about
a couple weeks before the Olympics so
what year was the Olympics in England oh
dude don't don't do this to me I think
it was 2000
No 2012 right so about seven years ago
that's about about right and the the
airport at Heathrow was insane and I was
praying God just give us grace because
with four kids jet-lagged we were stuck
in customs forever but we got through
spent some time in London
London's gorgeous it's incredible but we
had been like three months in Prague in
the city we want to just get out in the
country so we went to Northern Ireland
for a week and had just a blast you guys
have got some of the most beautiful
countryside in England and you just
recently you posted some pictures of
your new house I think on Facebook is
never good when where I'm we're renting
yeah okay I think you own about the that
looked amazing yeah beautiful house and
yeah so it loved England and I still
have a lot of friends in England I've
done a couple workshops in Spain
teaching people how to flip lease
options in England and it's a cool place
I'm glad you're here so not a lot of
people Sam you'll know about you here in
the US can you talk a little bit about
your history your story how did you get
started in real estate or property
I started probably just over ten years
ago and I I don't know how I've just got
back from the States
I'll probably you'll ask me about a bit
about the
challenge that I was doing but I bought
my first house it was an it was a no
money down deal and it was just before
the recession so I'm not just in the US
no well because the recession was like
worldwide so everything crashed so the
property market in the US it's same as
England so what my first house was just
before the recession and it was
basically a property that I put in a
family members name because I was too
young to get finance but I effectively
just bought it 100% financed and then
rented out so and the way I did that was
widened negotiating to buy below market
value buying it on a bridging room and
then refinancing up to its true value so
it was quite a creative deal so I did
that based on the back of going on a
course training program and those I was
literally you know pretty much just
fresh out of school and that was my
first house and then the recession came
and in one sense you could say I had
everything going against me like when
people come over excuses now you know I
can't do it because of this that the
other
you know I'm wasn't from a family of
property investors
my dad was an entertainer and a gardener
my mom a mobile hairdresser I didn't
have any money I was too young to get a
mortgage I don't have any particular
knowledge about property apart from I
was just learning at the course and it
was just on the brink of a massive
recession so it was you could argue that
everything was against me but with real
determination and a real reason a real
almost desperation to be financially
free because I really really didn't want
to work a job until I was 65 I just
don't want to do that so so yeah so I
began joint venturing and raising
finance and doing a little bit lease
options rent to rents all these
different creative strategies and I
guess I had nothing to lose sometimes
people think oh if you're on a hundred
thousand pounds salary and you can you a
bit comfortable it's easy but actually I
think it's really tough I mean people in
their in their 40s and 50s who have got
a wife to please who's used to having to
Range Rovers and three holidays a year
you know so let me pay check with four
kids and actually they've got a lot to
lose so it's difficult whereas me I was
I was learning about property but I've
absolutely nothing to lose I just really
went crazy went for it
and another just snowboard my portfolio
and now I've got a a ridiculously large
property portfolio no twenty-eight I
just bought a castle last year are you
really 20 28 years old yeah yeah I just
turned 20 I I was 27 last month
I would have thought you're in your mid
30s late 30s or something oh that's a
compliment is that because of my great
wisdom hopefully well just how much that
you've done yeah yeah when the success
that you've had yeah it's good to do it
I've got 31 members of staff we've got a
very large property trading company and
you know I'm building I mean the price
of just building six houses from scratch
on the other piece alone that we got up
in Lincoln so you know really
aggressively growing my property
portfolio but at the same time I've got
my training company and I'd do some I
just love making YouTube videos it's
like I pretty much pretty much most of
what I do these days when I'm thinking
I'll be driving an odd thing about
what's gonna be a cool project for a
YouTube video that's just constantly I
just I just love doing YouTube videos
and vlogging every time I buy a house
love it so that's and that's how I've
become well-known in the UK for my
youtube channel so I you know some of my
videos have really gone crazy well
what's funny by the way I was not and I
hope you wouldn't think I was rude I was
sharing our video it is live on Facebook
it's actually working I was sharing it
with everybody so again guys if you're
watching this say hello tell us where
you're from and if you have any
questions for Samuel go ahead and ask
them in here and I'll ask him you did
some crazy things one of the things I
liked about your videos Samuel is you
did one of them where you pretended you
didn't have any money yeah and you gave
yourself a deadline you can lock
yourself in a hotel room pretty much
right and Kourt I didn't pretend telling
Monet I just locked myself away I'm a
bank and literally had no no no you had
no money you took it all the way you
moved your access to it
you had your camera guy follow you
around and did you have a deadline of
how quickly you
had to do a deal or something like that
oh love yes sir I have fifty pound in my
pocket and I had a hotel room books for
seven days and after seven days if I
haven't made any money I would have just
been on the streets so it was it was a
case of you know make it or make your
break sort of the thing and the idea was
to try and make a deal happen from from
from from nothing apart from one
knowledge nice by the way did you see
this comment can you see that on the C
Daniels e thanks man I appreciate you
bro
he's actually from Cleveland Ohio you
have some fans from Cleveland Ohio and
this is Kevin from Coral Springs Florida
well some even periscope is on here nice
okay so this was so cool I mean this
these videos were really well done you
had this guy following me around I felt
like I was watching something on you
know like a documentary on TV or
something like that and it was like down
to the wire you were building the
tension and the stress of like oh no I
got to hurry up and do a deal
your wife was nervous worried for you
like what's gonna happen all right
she Kronk was off so talk talking about
what you did like you were in you took
away everything how did you find a deal
how long did it take you talk about yeah
so what happened was I well I actually
went to some blood property networking
events and stuff because I think the
first when you're starting out from
scratching you've got no money or
anything like that and Brutus Empire
great to have you here man I recognize
that name the thing the the first thing
is to get yourself in the right places
so to get down and you know get in front
of people meet other investors so I went
down to some property events and I was
obviously gence okay this is funny cuz
you were trying to hide yourself you're
wearing costumes had to being disguised
because then people would have said
unknown in England people did to deal
with you because they knew who you were
so I had this this wig and the glasses I
went by an alias name of Lucas Ruby and
obviously you know a different name so I
went to this property event and I was
undercover and I was trying to like talk
to people I was trying to network and
stuff but the the the event organizers
recognized me through
costume and freaked out I thought I was
trying to sabotage their event or
something I don't know what they thought
and then and then microphone and it was
awful but anyway well that what I did
was I've managed to find some apartments
for rent and I the the apartments were
owned by a developer who I spoke with
and this was in Sheffield and I said to
the owner I said if I was to give you a
guaranteed rent of X would it be okay if
I take it on as a corporate let and and
put my ex this is a few checks of stuff
had to do on that front and then the
idea was that I would put the property
on air B&B and and and booking.com
and rent the property out almost a
locker as a hotel we call this rent who
serviced accommodation I don't know if
you do the states that was the concepts
so I found two two deals and all that
boom shacka I've got the two deals
I run the numbers and I worked out that
from these two deals alone I would be
financially free all over again from
scratch however there's a big problem
and the problem was I needed some
upfront cash to pay the landlord upfront
to furnish the property just general
stuff it wasn't a lot of money but I
needed some quick cash so what I did was
I just told the the landlord and the
agent yeah I want the deal I'll get the
money to you in a couple days and then I
found a HMO and some below market value
deals and I basically wholesale flip
them whatever you call it holes in
England it's a little different what we
tend to do a quick deal packaging
whereby we find an opportunity we then
find an investor and then we pass the
opportunity that they're on to the
investor but charge an upfront fee so I
did that I made a point do you call it
sourcing properly sourcing or package a
crossing or deal packaging yeah okay
yeah cool well so I did that I made
eight thousand pound cash and my
videographer who was who was filming
this was freelance he was also a referee
he was like a little skeptical so he was
refereeing the whole thing every time I
did business if anyone will made any
money he would interview them and check
did you did you find out if they knew
who I was it was all done completely
like legit
and I made 8,000 pounds cash boom in my
new Lucas movie bank account
Lucas Looby limited and then with the
8,000 pounds I then took on my two
apartments which just still today be him
really well renting them out I'm making
good income off them and it was
literally just from scratching the whole
thing happened in seven days and that
video went viral I mean he just went
crazy and gay people so many people
spent much hope oh yeah I loved that
video I mean and Joe yeah I thought well
I've never heard of you and then we were
exchanging messages on Facebook a little
bit by the way you sent me a friend
request and I replied but you're at your
5,000 limit so you need to uh you need
to kick somebody out of your Friendship
Circle speaking I'm just kidding
so that was such an inspiring video and
I was encouraged by that and I even
shared it on my facebook because I
thought this is uh this is somebody that
I could tell you're a teacher because
you know you educate you help people and
people recognize you at that real estate
Club meeting or whatever but you're
actually out there doing it the stuff
which is so important in these days
isn't it there's so many people that are
teaching it from things that they've
done five ten years ago but aren't
currently active in the business today
right oh great yeah I'm great so uh one
of the things that we've been doing as
well is is with through lease options
turning them into air beam bees and I'm
sure it's exploding and doing really
well in England right now but in the
u.s. it's also been doing really well
where before you know like if you were
to package a deal together as a lease
option put somebody in the house you
might make three or four hundred dollars
a month in cash flow if you turn around
doing area B with it you can make a
thousand two thousand dollars a month in
cash yeah so are you seeing the same
thing right now in England taking
properties instead of just renting them
out but turning them into vacation
rentals how is this looking for you
right now
and and and how long is it gonna be
working Samuel great really good
question it's working there
very very well right now it's it's quite
unregulated in the UK so you don't need
to have a license you don't need to
there's there's very little regulation
around it as long as you've got consent
from the mortgage company to do it and
also if it's an apartment you need you
need a permission from the lease but
it's it's very unregulated HMOs
something that I do and that's very
regulated whereas serviced accommodation
is very young regulated I suspect it'll
probably get more difficult and it'll
probably regulations will come in then
also as more more people are doing it
it's of course gonna it's gonna mean
that there's more supply there's always
going to be demand so I think it's not
maybe at the moment you can do it oh
I'll just rent an apartment and rent it
out service to combinational air B&B and
make a load of money I think what maybe
down the line
even now I'm seeing you happen you need
to be a bit more careful about the area
you choose I'm a picture that there's a
real strong healthy demand but no it's
great and I mean just you know this this
challenge I did was only a few months
ago and my apartments are running out
really well and the cool thing is is you
don't even need to own the property be
or even have like an option to buy it or
anything you can literally just rent it
off the lot and then rent it this way
people say well why doesn't the laminal
just do himself a loop the obvious
answer is because he doesn't know how
and knowledge is everything in this
business people think all you need a lot
of money money helps but you can have
money but without knowledge you're
screwed but if you have knowledge so
however I don't know but I think that
maybe you've got to make hay while the
Sun shines
you know but at the same time a table
needs more than one leg so make hay
while the Sun shines but what I want to
encourage my students to do on my
YouTube videos is the profit that you're
making from the cash flow save it up and
put it into some slope and stuff why you
know buy to that or whatever yes yes one
of the things that's working well now in
in the US I'm seeing this and I'm
curious if you are - with Airbnb you
don't have to do Airbnb zin that in the
popular vacation areas of your city you
can do them in the smaller towns
in the more blue-collar working-class
neighborhoods
we're going next weekend to a small
little town in Iowa called Ankeny Iowa
and not a lot of people have heard of
that but you know I got four kids and
we're bringing our new dog that we just
got so we can't stay in a hotel guess
where I go I go to Airbnb and this is a
little town it's it's maybe half hour 45
minutes north of Des Moines Iowa CH is
the capital right but here's the thing
we found it's hard to find anything out
there
we found a four-bedroom house maybe
three bedroom two hundred dollars a
night two hundred bucks a night why
because there was nothing else out there
yes this guy can get away with charge so
there's still you you may think like oh
man and only I can only do Airbnb and
expensive areas or the touristy areas
that's not true there's a lot of
opportunity in the areas where it's
smaller town in the blue-collar
working-class areas because people are
going and looking instead of going to
the hotels they're going to Airbnb and
they're looking for places that they can
stay for a few days and have their own
kitchen great well it's so true and I
think there's two when you do in a deal
like this which is going to be an Airbnb
or booking.com deal we call it serviced
accommodation there's two things that
you need number one is you just need to
make sure that you got the right
permissions and all the legalities
everything's good and everything's done
properly and legally number two is you
need to make sure that there's a demand
and how you find out the demand if
there's hotels in the area then a demand
wait so how strong the demand is is to
just try and book the hotel and if you
if you can't ever book the hotel who's
always full then it's like boom shocka
but you should just just look speak to
the ìiî even do this right now I'm in my
home in Litchfield and in the whole city
of Litchfield it's not a big city but it
is a city there's only two hotels and
they're both always full so I'm thinking
actually I might I might as an
investment area I don't think mitch
field is great but it's you know it'll
work for a service combination so
there's a
the cool thing the the cool thing too is
that there's less regulation in those
smaller towns isn't there well when I
was in New York I couldn't do it they
were what's so restricted you know with
the rules and stuff but then I moved
slightly outside ended up in New Jersey
Philadelphia only an hour and a half but
suddenly I mean I mean Philadelphia is a
different state so it was just oh okay
so yeah I want to talk about this this
is so cool yeah what Samuel did guys
he went he's got a big social media
following in England right and by the
way you're getting dark outside so if I
lose the internet we'll get back on here
in a minute how can it go dark and then
you lose internet doesn't make any sense
I didn't get high speed internet because
I'm out in the suburbs
you know about 45 minutes from the city
but I'm out in the sticks and we didn't
get high-speed Internet till about a
year ago though okay so it's still kind
of spotty anyway so Samuel has a big
social media following and he goes on
Facebook live and he just had a
harebrained idea he said I'm gonna go to
the United States he's at the airport
wouldn't what is it so after I did my
financial freedom challenge in England
yes yes it was there was this there was
people in different countries saying you
could never do that in my country you
can never do that in my country so I
said okay so I went to an airport near
my house I've got a Facebook live out
and I said where do you want me to go
folks work wherever then know what
whoever says the country the most like
whichever country comes up the most
I'll just tubs fly that so I didn't plan
on going to America
but I put live video the States was
coming up more than any other country
the second one was Australia and the
third one was Germany so I was like so I
literally just there and then went to
the States jumped on a plane I've got an
s2 at the airport and people saying can
you do that though do you not need a
working visa I'm like I don't know but
sometimes you just gotta just step out
and see what happens I mean terrible
was gonna succeed my plan was going you
know in a foreign country with no money
I don't never was gonna succeed or not I
could just go try it so that was the
difference the difference was I didn't
go to the States
I went to an airport not knowing where I
was going because I was I'm very happy
to go anywhere because I believe that
when you have the knowledge and you're a
property entrepreneur has the knowledge
I believe that the skills were pretty
much just about work anywhere but on
that task itself there just restrict and
sell you know to that to that country so
did you every camera guy with go with
you and film it yep
the whole time probably while I was
sleeping alright so where did you fly
into the u.s. I flew into New York City
okay and what did you the whole I mean
the actual footage you could be
concealed on YouTube
but I go to New York City and I just
started stopping strangers in the street
in New York City saying talk to me about
the property market here you know do you
buy or do you rent do you own or do you
rent how much do you pay and I was just
literally doing that then I just started
making making phone calls do a state
agent brokers real estate brokers saying
can I meet you as soon as possible
please to discuss your properties that
you're saying and I just got loads of
viewings lined up and properties in New
York in New York City and paraca in New
York but I very quickly realized that
New York was going to be really tough
because lease option agreements the way
I do them you need motivated sellers
particularly people that have got
negative equity in New York they'll not
know that and there is not negative
equity because the market is just
absolutely it's not it's just crazy
rent to rents you can't do it's not
allowed in New York I didn't know any of
this I had to figure out was there
they have like a rule or rule within New
York City where you can't do it and I
just realized that my strategies weren't
them to work in New York now people in
New York would say I live in New York
and strategies don't work but the thing
is there's a reason that we have cars so
I just drove a little bit outside I went
to Staten Island and New Jersey then
Philadelphia frantically viewing loads
of houses
knocking on doors talking with
real-estate brokers and solicitors going
crazy this is a connection with you
because I was just doing just all these
options legal in the States couldn't
even if there wasn't meat or not ah is
went to rent legally I'm just doing all
this stuff because I don't know I don't
if it's legal not your name popped up
and I thought ah Joe McCall and it says
Joe McCall lease options blah blah blah
blah I just joked on Facebook mrs. Jim
hey I need to chat to you and you too
late I know I'm kicking myself because
it was a week later yeah I think you
know what you're like assistant maybe
message me and just assume it like um
Joe's very busy but he'll get back to
you before so anyway so I know man you
know what I probably the same someone
message made some crazy person from the
state's mrs. Benoit I'm in England but I
ended up negotiating the deal in
Philadelphia which was a lease option
agreement deal which is basically a
no-money-down
deal and it was incredible and you can
you can see the whole negotiations and
how I structured the deal and everything
like that on YouTube but he was insane
and put it out there and the cool thing
is even a guy that I just saw in this
channel I think his name was Brutus
he he there he is knowledge is key this
is him I believe and he can correct me
if I'm wrong but he said because he's
been following you for a while he's been
following me I went to the spikes and
did a lease option agreement there are
people and he's one of them who are now
getting Lease Option agreements and
doing deals normally down deals and
stuff as a result of watching these top
it says yeah so
Brutus congratulations on your new lease
option agreement man people you know
saying oh my gosh I just did the same
thing now after watching you do it so
and a lot of people credit use well I've
seen a lot of people credit yourself
because this is so not there's so few
people that teach because just did first
Lease Option deal good man I'd like for
people message me in the last week from
mistakes saying I've just done a lease
option or I've just done or this I've
just done of that as
watching the video in the states they're
possibly the same people that would have
moaned a few months ago and said it only
works in England it doesn't any work in
England I mean of course there's
different rules in different countries
and you've got to be careful and you've
got to know your stuff but there's
always there's you can count the things
you can't do or you can count the things
you can do okay so this deal you got you
found a motivated seller yeah under card
you how did you get the contracts what
contracts did you use I basically did it
is a little bit of a joint venture so I
found somebody who was a real estate
broker
I found the deal then I found a real
estate broker who knew knew of the deal
in there and I did it as a lease option
agreement but I said I want the comes
depreciation but I'll give you all of
the cash flow if you just saw everything
because I knew I was gonna be going back
to England I didn't want I didn't want I
didn't want the headache all the hassle
yeah so so there's a really good really
good for him really good for me everyone
was happy and I didn't put a penny now
did you find a tenant buyer to live in
the house before you left
oh no okay no attendant so you guys you
guys do tenant buyers like do you even
understand Joe do you understand that
what I mean because well I think when
when the people in the state's a lease
option agreement and when I say a lease
option agreement for England I think
they mean different things like well
maybe there is a lot of similarities
tell me what it is what's that lease
option agreement a lease option
agreements where you find a seller and
you you you come to an agreement to
lease their property for a couple of
years with an option to buy it in the
future okay so what do you what do you
need a tenant law why can't you just put
a normal time well you could certainly
and but most people will do what's
called a sandwich lease option right so
we have the a to be where we have an
agreement with the seller and then we
have the B to C where we will rent it
you guys may be so complicated
ah a BT next why what okay there's two
different ways to do it I wrote a book
on that we call it I call it wholesaling
lease options and I think
another spanner in the works now
night-night this is what I wanted to
talk to you while I was out there
because everything's so confusing let me
tell you what these option agreement is
to me you tell me if it's the same maybe
maybe maybe you'll make more money I
don't know you might make more money
doing it but I'm loving this combo I'm
loving this combo so for me a lease
option is this you buy a property now
and you pay for it later
so yeah that's a different way that's a
good way to put it yeah you buy it now
you pay for it later
you take own it you take control of it
you rent it out you pay the landlord
even mortgage payments or or or a small
fee and then anything left over when you
rent it you keep that cash flow and then
down the line you have the option to buy
it and that you hope that the values
gone up so you've made that you've made
rent each month and capital appreciation
if it hasn't gone up in your owner to
buy it you have the option not the
obligation but he has the obligation
yeah that's a lease option but but then
wholesaling and sandwich lease option
they're going all that stuff it's for
and someone well what you just described
I would call a sandwich lease option
okay okay so you're I'm staying in the
middle and I'm collecting the difference
in rent sound I'm gonna yeah I'm staying
in the middle like a sandwich that's
what it sounds option but they're more
like maybe I gave someone else
the monthly cash flow he'll either at
least a sandwich lease option and then
he almost did a rent to rent on my
sandwich nice option to relieve me of
the head like so yeah then you you uh
you made the money from the the tenant
who lived in the house that they put
down a deposit right there wasn't it was
an empty house it was an empty house the
mortgage was fifty nine thousand pounds
fifty nine year fifty nine thousand
pound he had it on the market
was it fifteen or sixteen oh sorry sixty
nine sixty nine thousand he had it on
the market for seventy-five and I worked
out if he saw at the 75 father Tommy
pays his fees and stuff he's gonna be
left with nothing he's all good is gonna
go straight to the mortgage back the
mortgage company so if I just say to him
hello you struggling to sell it for 75
and even if you got what you wanted
you'd make nothing
how about I'll just take you on and I
bought off you for 75 in five years time
and in the meantime give you X a month
okay so that hold up hold on one second
yes yes but I'm on the I'm on the phone
right now few minutes sorry so you've
got how much rent spread were you making
so yeah the mortgage payment was what
and what was the rent that you're
commendable
which 191 pounds so we said we'll pay
him 200 pound a month and then the rent
would be somewhere I don't believe
there's a tenant in there yet because
I've literally got back from the states
only a couple weeks ago so it's still
we're still going through all the
contracts and stuff but the the rent
will be somewhere between eight hundred
and a thousand and we're paying him 200
so the cash flow is really good now
anyone that's watching and thinking
fellas watching us thinking like it's an
ethical you know what would he wente
himself or you know part of our
strategies I always tell the landlord I
always say your best option is to rent
it out yourself
you know it's your best option and only
when they say I don't want to do that
I'd only be a landlord I exhaust all the
options first and then give them this as
like a last resort so yeah that's pretty
good
so the cash flow is going to be pretty
good but but as I said what I did and
call me crazy but I sacrificed 100
percent of the monthly cash flow because
I've passed it on to a wholesaler out
there and I've said to him look you can
keep all of the cash flow but I want you
to just manage it and deal with it cuz I
don't really care about the cash flow
but I have the option to buy it for 75
in five years and the market is trending
so I'm thinking I'll probably end up
making a whole lot of capital growth out
there in five years time so that'sthat's
basically I have the eye of the I have
the the almost a benefit because it in
property you get paid twice you get paid
in cash flow and you get paid in capital
appreciation one pays the bills and one
gets you rich so yes our friend Brutus
here says so the way we do it we give
the option to buy to our tenants yeah
you keep the property and you just put a
regular tenant yeah
the property his back yeah crass correct
say when I was talking to people about
these options though when I was in the
States
I was saying like I was talking to
people I might be speaking with you know
a solicitor or a broker and antenna what
I'm doing and then yeah yeah I
understand these options but then when I
started to do it in practice they'd be
like whoa it would almost free
I think it's people's understood but now
you call it option maybe that's what I
should have said and they were who knows
don't you you I like your approach to it
is a little simple of language you use a
little simpler in some ways but one of
the strategies that I like to do what
allowed me to quit my job back in 2009
is I would find a seller that had a
property that didn't have much equity or
didn't even have much cash flow in it
and I would get it under a lease option
contract and then I would just sell that
lease option contract or a sign that
contract to a tenant who was going to
take my place and then I stepped away
completely out of the deal and I would
make anywhere you know five to ten grand
sometimes three
yeah but I'm making about five thousand
dollars on that so that's what I call it
a wholesaling lease option or lease
option assignment Thanks I know you can
do as well is in five years time and
I'll have the option to buy it for 75 if
it's doubled in value let's say that
it's worth 150 and I'm like boom and
I've got 70,000 70,000 my equity rather
than buy it for 75 I can then sell it
for 150 and just keep keep the profit
now yeah exactly
I'm because people get stressed happy
block but you know it's not know me down
because in five years you have to buy it
but no I'll have to buy it in five years
I have the option to buy it in 75 but if
it's any he's got up more than that I
can just keep the difference oh I can
just buy five and then we finance it
like the world is your own and when
you've got a 75 grand property that's
worth 150
well that's the great thing about
options lease options is they give you a
lot of flexibility there's different
things you can do with it you know you
can keep it and put it make it an Airbnb
you can put a tenant in there and just
rent it out you could sell your lease
option to the tenant and then
walk away or you could actually maybe
just rent it out for five years if
there's enough equity at the back end
you actually buy it hold on to it yeah
that's great it's we we like to say here
it's control without ownership does that
make sense yeah yep
Billy percent I mean we're a bit
obsessed in the UK we've owning things
but you know I regularly say this on
YouTube the most successful companies
that control rather than own like Amazon
don't own their stock they control it
uber and their taxis they just control
they just control loads of loads of
massive massive companies they don't own
they just control that's good so we're
getting a lot of people out here
commenting from YouTube and this guy
works in Woodbridge North New Jersey
cool yeah New Jersey yeah
British says here so Samuel is doing
better than us I am just lol I'm just
going to rent it instead of doing a
lease option well okay here you can do
both one of the reasons why I will put a
tenant buyer in the house because
sometimes I in order to pass on the
responsibilities of the maintenance and
repairs of the property I don't want
just a regular tenant in the house I
want somebody who once who wants to buy
it in the future and is going to take
care of in the maintenance and repairs
of that right that makes perfect sense I
taste something as well anyone that's
watching this who's maybe thinking it
sounds too good to be true because it
kind of does sound too good to be true I
mean it blows your mind a little bit
when we're taught all our lives that we
have to work really hard save up all our
money and then when it's big enough for
a deposit on a house buy a house which
is the biggest investment you'll ever
make
and then when talking about are you just
control this property and you can do
these things and it can sound a little
bit too good to be true but I'll just
say even myself and you've got all the
experience I've been in the game for
over a decade all the knowledge and
stuff like that when I was in the States
I got a lot of rejection before I got my
deal you know I've got a lot of
rejection and you can you can literally
on the from the video you should watch
it you'd already seen the you know I get
door slam
in my face I get told no no no time and
time again you know quite some people
get really quite opportune and stuff so
it's it kind of um you know it is
possible but of course it takes it takes
work you've got to be prepared to to get
a know people say oh it doesn't work you
know because I tried it well what did
you actually do I made three phone calls
and spoke to one person come on you know
you can't say doesn't work after making
three calls and speaking to one person
you've got a really you got to speak to
a hundred people and and even on the
first day of my challenge in the States
I made over a hundred and twelve phone
calls Wow and I only spoke to nine
people and get invoice mail after
voicemail after voicemail after
voicemail you know I was losing the will
to live was so depressing and and I'll
so bummed out and I was like oh my
goodness and I can't get hold of anyone
it's really depressing but then the
following day some of those people that
got through to voicemail so I'd phone me
back and it began to pick up so it just
takes perseverance and hard work which I
think a lot of I'm missing in people's
actions I've often said the 3m2 success
in this business is marketing momentum
and mentor marketing is a foundation of
everything right you got us plant the
seeds you got to throw out the marketing
but it takes time to build that momentum
so many people get impatient don't they
yeah I'm like if I don't get a lead now
if I don't get a deal now it doesn't
work but the momentum builds slowly as
you're consistently marketing the
momentum starts to grow and then you
know give it a couple months three
months and that those deals that you
start doing are not from the new leads
that came in they're from the leads that
came in from before and following up
with I was just talking to one of my
students today Dustin San Diego he's
doing deals in Oklahoma right now and
the deals he's averaging about five
deals a month right now and these deals
that he's doing right now have been from
at least the last three to six months of
follow-up right just continually calling
and texting emailing sending letters and
gonna follow up taking building that
momentum right absolutely absolutely and
was a third M mentor yes you
oh yeah a real cool guy next time Samuel
I want to challenge you to not come to
the US you can do all of that over the
phone
super easily like you know it's
important to go see the house if you can
but when I was in Europe when we were
living in Prague and traveling around
Europe for three months we even did this
while we were traveling around the US
and an RV for three months we did all of
our deals over the phone without ever
even seeing the house right it's just a
matter of marketing we do a lot of text
messages we we send a lot of direct mail
and text messages one of the cool things
about investing in the US is we have an
easier time pulling data from public
records in with it took me a few days to
figure it out and I'm like you can just
see the addresses of the houses for sale
and you can let see who owns them who
owns it and how much they paid for it
and you can find the homes that are
negative equity and targets I'm like wow
if this was in the UK it is yeah
hey like my goodness but again it goes
back to you just gotta take the take the
cards you've been handed and and make as
much money as you can bit like in the UK
there's advantages in the u.s. there's
advantages I'm sure in South Africa in
Germany and Holland there's always
there's always pros and cons of every
country and you're just gonna take the
pros and run with it I love what you did
man that is so cool
I think it's inspiring I get cuz one
time Samuel I had two students in the
same city complained within two days of
each other one student was saying
there's not enough sellers here I can
find tons of buyers but no sellers the
other student in the same city says I
can find tons of sellers I can't find
any buyers this doesn't work
same city within a couple days of each
other right I think it's all up a matter
of perspective like you just came here
and you said I'm gonna figure this out I
don't care you know like how many times
I have to fail I know there are deals
here and and I'm not gonna be I don't
know if I could have done what you just
did that's that's crazy right but like
you just determined to make it happen
and it worked
so people got to stop making excuses you
don't know
thanks Carol yeah oh man that that is
the reason that I keep doing these
challenges I just keep doing them just
to pull the excuses removing the
people's feet so they can you know and
when you do that what happens when you
take excuses away from people they
either react one or two ways number one
is they just get angry or upset because
it's like how dare you take away my
comfort excuse because it challenges
them or number two is they just pull the
finger out get to work and get some
results and see it seen the success of
people I mean there's people in England
making headlines in the newspapers just
for their outrageous success just from a
result of watching my youtube videos and
the satisfaction that that gives me you
know putting stuff out for free people
watch and then become financially free
it is just super rewarding and I think
success successes is is is great but
significance is even greater why don't
you say you get more excited seeing your
students - deals than doing deals
herself potentially yeah because you
know your first deal it's always your
hardest deal so my first deal in the
States was really hard if I went back I
probably belt you three or four deals in
a week so it's always the hardest so
today if I do a deal it's not really a
big deal it's just okay I've completed
on the house today it's no big deal
whereas if one of our students does a
deal it's a real big deal so from
because it's a big deal for them it
becomes a big deal to me so yeah I did
get more excited about it unless it's a
massive deal for me like like when I
bought my castle last year geez that was
nice for me that was a real big deal
because it's it's a multi-million pound
project so but just yeah pens on the
deal but I love okay okay real excited
yet seeing people do well seen people's
minds changed and seeing people get out
of their jobs and I think there's a
rippling effect as well because people
usually basically people have got a real
good reason to do it if people want to
become financially free so they can then
go and you know sell charities and be
with their family and really good stuff
and then you can help them do that and
then they can then live the life they
want and then inspire others to do the
same and it's like a rippling effect
making the world a better place as
cheesy as it sounds it's good that's
good hey do you have a time for a few
questions yeah okay good
guys if you have questions you're
watching this right now on Facebook or
YouTube type them in the comments down
below we only got a few more minutes
with Samuel but I'm gonna go through
some questions here that I see but real
quick while I'm looking at this question
Sam well how can people find you what's
your YouTube channel if you have a
website and so I which is property -
investors dot coat UK but probably best
is to just put my name into YouTube
that's probably the best things deterred
cube is really where it's at for me so I
know obviously Instagram and a lot of
stuff so if he just put Samuel Leeds in
YouTube and then just check out some of
the videos there's videos on on buying
properties on renting properties on
lease oxygens on deal packaging all
kinds of stuff and I also interview like
every every week I interview one of my
success students and okay a brain and
say it's just a brilliant channel so
yeah check it out man good this is from
Facebook Daniel a little off subject but
can you make a lease option offer to a
homeowner that is represented by a
realtor you call him solicitors okay so
a realtor does that broker he's not like
an estate agent always a yes
a solicitor is a solicitor as an
attorney or a lawyer right all right
yeah you can't down you yes in fact my
ideal that all I did was represented by
a realtor and what I did and you need to
check out the video on billion percent
but what I did was the realtor didn't
want me to do the deal because he
wouldn't have got his face so that's all
I told the realtor that he can manage
the property and keep the cash flow if
he lets me do the deal so it was through
a realtor but you just need to always be
thinking what's in it for them whenever
you whenever II didn't because this
what's in it for the realtor what's in
it for the seller wasn't it for the you
can in in the state's down you can put
anywhere to do anything so you can
definitely do that would you say it's
easier doing creative deals in the US or
in the UK I think it's quite similar so
I looked into like HMOs the regulations
are pretty similar least options are
pretty similar I'm not sure if you can
can you do rent two rents in the states
where you rent something and then
yes maybe India whatever if you did
properly yeah there's um yeah if you
could get it seller to agree to it you
know there's a couple things that you
need in the contract to make it valid
need some kind of consideration some
kind of exchange you need signatures and
an agreement of the minds I think is
what it's called right right no okay
yeah it's it's you can do events events
are good I think it's quite similar I
think the thing that I noticed in the
states where I was anywhere because the
states is saying the states he's kind of
silly because it's so massive but where
I was
I think this massive opportunity for to
buy property do it up and then sell it I
was coming across people that had bought
property and I couldn't get a deal from
them because I'm trying to negotiate a
lease option on them and they just don't
need money they just don't leave my deal
because then more produces its
development they've spent twenty
thousand on it so they put thirty six
thousand in total and and now it's worth
like eighty thousand I was I was seeing
that and I know the stats because
because I can see on on the online cuz
it's all public information and I was
speaking to the seller about the work
that done it's just insane so it really
gave me a bug to want to buy a property
do it up and said I think this you make
a lot more money doing that in the
States than you would in England
certainly at the moment we're like
brexit and stuff and some of the
uncertainty around that so I think
strategy pen I think that it's probably
similar the opportunity in the States
and in the UK is probably similar
depending on state depending on strategy
but massive opportunity in both and I
can't wait to go and figure some stuff
out in some of the countries like
Germany and Holland and South Africa
Australia I interviewed a guy Rick art
and we talked about him earlier um he
was when I last interviewed him he was
in Greece doing some deals in Greece and
I couldn't believe it at first I was
thinking like you don't even speak Greek
how do you do the deals like you know
any of those obstacles that most people
would be intimidated with and pull away
from you can make you can make the
choice you can turn around and walk away
where you can blast right through it and
so he just brought a translator with
them he brought a solicitor or a an
agent broker whatever
in Greece brought them with them and
just talked to people and was doing
deals so you're asking about rent to
rent well we might call it a master
lease here in the US where you you get a
property under a lease with the seller
with the right to sublease it out to a
tenant buyer a lot of people that are
doing Airbnb here have a similar
agreement where they just tell the
seller listen I'll pay you the rent that
you're asking for and I'll take care of
all the maintenance and vacancies and
repairs you don't have to worry about
any of that yeah just let me turn around
and do it on do an Airbnb on it and I
have one student this is so cool ad once
didn't negotiate with the seller to keep
all of the furniture in the house so the
seller kept the furniture in the house
she's paying the seller full asking rent
for three years and that's all the
seller wanted you know they just wanted
to get somebody in the house and then he
was gonna take care of it within four
days so she's paying 1250 a month in
rent twelve hundred and fifty dollars a
month in rent within four days of
putting it on Airbnb she already had
twelve hundred and forty five dollars
yeah I see the same thing happening here
all the time
it's incredible yeah and then the
opportunity the opportunity yeah now
he's so good he's so good good stir
that's great story all right so one more
two more questions here real quick I
appreciate your time subletting is legal
in all states correct
subletting I'm believing what you mean
by that is like subleasing subleasing it
out is that what subletting is is what
we talk when you rent a property and
then you rear-end someone and one more
thing from what you've said Kevin I
think what Joe's saying is it's legal as
long as you do it properly as long as
you do with the right contracts and
everything like that they're just
getting really education I'm sure yeah
Oh Jacob
my favorite question oh I haven't seen a
deal since it's like seen a house that I
wholesaled since probably eight or nine
years and and even when I was doing
deals in my own backyard here in st.
Louis Missouri
the house would be 30 minutes away and
it was too far for me I didn't want to
go there I had to I didn't have enough
time I was working my full-time job I
had my family and kids at home if I
would have taken that drive out there we
got stuck on traffic on the way back and
so I just determined in my mind you know
what I'm going to do these deals over
the phone and that's why I love lease
options so much because at least for me
it's so much easier to negotiate a lease
option deal than a deep discount at 60
65 50 cents on the dollar for a for what
we call a wholesale deal but they're
easier to negotiate over the phone and
so I'm telling you a lot of people get
intimidated by that like how could I do
a deal without ever going to look at the
property I think what Samuel just did
was brilliant he found somebody local
there and he partnered with them I do
most of my deals now we JB and partner
with local Realtors local investors I've
done deals in over ten different states
from four different countries while
traveling and it's all been by
understanding marketing getting systems
in place getting a lot of virtual
assistants to do that stuff for me but
then partnering with local boots on the
ground people maybe it's a realtor maybe
it's a another investor and joint
venture with them on the deal that way
you can do way more deals and it's it's
it's a lot easier a lot easier one of
the one of the best things about doing
that by the way too is when you're
parting with somebody local you can get
access to their resources their
contracts their their solicitors their
attorneys their title companies that can
help you prepare the deal if you had to
borrow money get property management
whatever yeah yes sir one more question
and then we'll call it a day Samuel
Cliff where do you get negative equity
leaves where do you get them anyway in
England what I do is I go on to write
moves which is a little bit like what is
it what's the name of yours is it like
Zillow or something yeah right news
which is the equivalent so where you can
various houses and you can find
properties and then what you have to do
is you have to find properties whereby
they were bought say oh no ten year
ago and the values have dropped so if
you can find you this is all public
information on Zillow or whatever these
websites were depending on what country
or state you're in so if you can find a
property whereby they bought it and now
they're selling it for less sorry yeah
for less than they paid for it a long
time ago what what that tends to mean is
that unless they bought it cash that I
bought it with a mortgage let's say they
put on 20% deposit 80% mortgage if it's
dropped they've now got no equity at all
so so that's how I do it and then I'll
usually just send them a letter or um
you know post them a card or something
just say hey i noticed that you sell in
you property's been on a while would you
be interested in a renter by top scheme
where i can take over the property
become the landlord and give you a fixed
fee down the line but give the market a
chance to recover a few interest to give
me a shell yeah that's good by the way
we don't say scheme here that sounds a
little spammy we love the word
scheme it sounds like it's sneaky or
something no no no scheme sounds like
what official maybe it's just me I don't
know well you know one of the one of the
things I was gonna say is really funny
the the guy that I coach with my
coaching business partner his name is
Gavin he's from England he's been in the
US for maybe five six seven years yeah
he all sales a lot he does a lot of
deals with me and it's funny he tells
the story he's like I don't want to go
in these houses and look at it because
if I did I wouldn't know what I was
looking at like he would have any idea
yeah it would actually be a hindrance to
him to because he doesn't know how much
it costs to replace the flooring or what
what is a good furnace or a bad furnace
you know what I'm saying interestin yeah
you know what sometimes being small can
actually hinder you and hold you back
I'll say well when I when I do a lease
option agreement deal what I tend to do
negative equity leads or a few hours
from my house I don't view them either I
don't view them I will find them online
send them a letter they'll then phone me
I'll do the negotiations over the phone
then I'll take their word for it on the
condition so I'll say them look what's
the condition does it need work was the
ocean-based
photos and their word I'll take them at
their word but I'll tell them subject to
ya they want to random and the head of
term signs before I complete on the
lease option I'll get a survey on the
property it cost me 300 quid I'll get a
server on the property and then the
surveyor will go around with a
fine-tooth comb and give me the accurate
this is the condition and if then it's
they've lied to me I'll pull out of the
deal and I've lost 300 quid and it's a
pain but the way that you position the
conversation and stuff usually they'll
give you a free honest you know
description but what I say Jo on that
point is the surveyor is going to have a
much better idea than I would have
because I'm pretty good and pretty
knowledgeable but he has all his tools
and stuff you know he goes round we've
always damp measuring and all this stuff
so he's he's gonna have more of an idea
so people say you can't give what you
bought it blind
I didn't buy blind I bought it educated
based on what other people have told me
who have actually more informed than I
am so I think that yeah is a really
really good point what you said one of
the things that we're doing is we're
using what we call mobile notaries so a
notary is somebody that can go and get
something officially signed and put a
stamp on it and so we're hiring these
mobile notaries instead of getting these
contracts signed electronically or
digitally we're sending a notary to the
house it only cost about 50 to 100 bucks
we're sending them to the house they're
getting the paperwork signed right then
in there and then they're walking around
the house taking pictures and filling
out a report sending it to us but that
that's another topic for those things
all right so we've got we're out of
questions we've got Jacob we're saying
thank you you welcome the end and then
Brutus says lol scheme they use that all
the time scheme all right okay so um
guys you can get more information go to
Samuel Leeds youtube channel at real
estate investing mastery com I will have
a link to these videos that we're
talking about you can go watch them
check them out follow him on Facebook
follow him on YouTube I'm looking
forward saemmul to getting to know you
more helping you in any way I can I'm
here in the States and it's been a great
podcast I appreciate you sharing you
know what I appreciate you having the
what's the politically correct polite
way to say it the piece the balls to
come here to the US
and and show us off like listen if this
guy from England it doesn't know how we
do deals here can come to the u.s. and
do deals what's your excuse
yeah I love it thank you for doing that
thank you thank you all right we'll see
you guys later again go to real estate
investing master e.com to get the show
notes to get the links and even get a
transcript of this podcast as well we'll
see you guys later take care bye bye